faz uns o que construí com foscos a olha
a bola sozinho em uma série que vamos
acender bola em 325 vai onde só de quem
fala é o dar que sejam muito bem vindos
a mais um meia e um estrago de que mais
um videogame suave no vídeo de hoje
vamos mostrar cinco truques com fósforos
olha aí opus a cometer uma loucura o meu
deus pois é isso ai meu deus
opel é olha é isso muito lucro
estou muito empolgado para fazer este
vídeo porque construiu uma coisa muito
louca com forte mas um só que construir
com foscos olha isso é uma bola gigante
fosse percebeu que era muito difícil
acho que vai dar um efeito muito pouco
tempo muito pouca que a volta é este é
um dos truques com fotos só sabe se
quiserem que você ainda está aqui deixei
muito à equipe neste vídeo eo quarto
colocado um vídeo por dia portanto não
foi inscrito aqui no canal inscrevam e
carrega em si nem pra não perder nenhum
vídeo é e 21 sou nem na primeira nem
cabeça lei é muito grande a loura já
sabem pessoal não façam isso em casa
sério vocês podem se magoar mesmo apesar
de serem só fósforo eu não quero fazer
isso também é tentar fazer essas coisas
em casa portanto não faça em casa pois
uma equipe de virtual oferece um vasto
leque foi muita que o canal porque vou
continuar a fazer este tipo de coisas
que se fazem de estarem também comentem
e dar faz cinco grupos com qualquer
coisa é porque eu acho que vou treinar
em cima cérebro que eu já fiz um centro
escolar é então se quiserem ver alguns
truques sobre qualquer coisa específica
comenta e que eu posso fazer para lá
então só fazer e que os 5 truck eu já
tenho material tudo aqui olha isso muito
material
olha com tirar fotos pois projetos que
também já se registaram na época o
street com o estudo a montar esta bola
meu o ex-ministro é muito grande e
também tem aqui uma novidade o meia se
tornou o herói eu me sinto muito grande
só de estar em sintonia
já sabes responsável da fama foi que
tudo fosse o uso se tornou uma máxima
tudo só voltar agora 321 vai
o opel como fazer expediu aqui dentro e
eu vou usar fux vai começar a ler eu já
uso cinto gente está sempre chego lá
oi boa noite pessoal primeiro truque
para este grupo vai ser preciso de um
pouquinho coisa é só olha só
vocês precisam de dois postos um
pouquinho mas sim é e uma moeda e pode
ser uma moeda qualquer e isso vocês
podem fazer qualquer pessoa quando vão
comer fora quando o restaurante quando
você come que dá pra fazer toda a gente
à nossa família em casa e eu quero fazer
justiça afirmou então eu quero faça
embora - am após contigo tu ganhas
justifica com o euro
se eu perder eu quero que estejam com as
coisas afluxo ganhar um percurso e um
desafio aos 15 eu vou colocar aqui mas
sim é e vou deixar aqui foto vai ficar
aqui em pé eu vou deixar a moeda aqui
por baixo e vou colocar aqui este outro
fósforo é difícil colocar um fosso do
jogo eu tenho é mesmo o termo muito ter
é um erro foi estranho porque se falar
muito alto que o time então o desafio
assim tomar é que tem que tirar a moeda
daqui sem tocar nos postos e seus
consumos caírem não é não é possível
excluir o desafio agora pneu e vai
fazendo a empresa não foi assim não dá
pra sair só em saber sobre isso eu
comentei em baixo e vamos ver como é que
um ano com aquele sol visto que pode
fazer não vai cair tudo
mas atentados ainda não se tornou o
zagueiro
vamos falar só segunda tentativa eu acho
que vou ganhar uma moeda
só vamos falar claro aqui então este
troféu ao local encontrou é muito
simples olha aí não é só pegar um
dinheiro tudo desde um isqueiro meu e
perguntar se alguém me provar não só
agora mas vai acontecer para que seu
irmão john f o natal é bom né
na passarela do frango
agora essa final da moeda a lei é mais
dia menos dia olha só complicou foto
olha isso é preciso uma escultura agora
é tão só ao fundo truck com fósforos que
este é muito bom serviço é muito bom
porque o próprio já testei contava fazer
um churrasco lá embaixo e estreou sua
autoria que só tocou ou como é que isso
é possível mas uma pequena e não viu
isto porque o fisco no início da casa do
problema porque não vi isso e muito mais
virá agora meu é muito louco cérebro
então o copo o copo um copo não li a
sinopse dos gases dos carros que mais
que o foco não o primeiro copo dos
garotos e um fóssil não deste truque é o
truque do equilíbrio impossível eu posso
também fazer em casa é só juntar assim
os fósforos fóssil
os garotos mas somente assim o lugar
você já fazia equilíbrio mas pareceu que
eu vou fazer agora qualquer fosse um
ataque bem no meio e vejam só 321 vai só
conectar equilibrado o meu tá mesmo na
ponta do fósforo como a cinza e parece
impossível
foram então sua própria centro que é o
foco do foguete
vamos lá para fazer o nosso foguete nós
precisamos de papel alumínio e claro ao
claro fósforos primeiro nós vamos fazer
é cortar a cabeça de um foto é isso que
vai dar início ao nosso foguete embora
ela é calma calma eu vou deixar aqui não
só para não faltar lá valetta aqui de lá
pessoal do próximo passo é só enrolar o
nosso ver com a cabeça do fósforo num
papel domínio é mais ou menos assim é só
deixar o ferro aqui só que o cara que a
cabeça do fósforo e erro a não vai ver
uma cueca elas b em 2008 o que só agora
está tudo pronto para lá então ascender
a cabeça do forno e eu espero que
funcione mas eu estou com muito medo
estou com muito medo de escuro
a amazônia legal é pesquisado nas obras
teve uma ideia melhor eu vou deixar aqui
a massinha e vou deixar aqui o lançador
do foto olha aí sim apoia o plano agora
vai agora sim embora ressaltasse basta
pra lá
o orçamento agora 321 vai meu deus meu
deus não aconteceu nada eu acho que os
maiores fregueses
ok fogo não funcionam vamos fazer o mais
potente agora bota tereré é que está o
nosso tão eu já coloquei lá acho que
esse esforço vamos ver se funciona 321
vai o visto como muito fumo em baixo
aqui qualquer coisa mal ainda não só não
precisa pois o árbitro então eu não vou
conseguir fazer agora mostrar o vídeo
mais à frente e vou tentar trazer um
foguetão com fotos que funciona caema já
me disse que funciona portanto vocês
podem experimentar em casa sendo que os
nossos pais proprietário foram então
pessoal para 14 que porque gosto com um
martelo na mão porque esses quatro que
envolve o martelo e vocês já vão
conseguir porque depois terão materiais
uma tela papel alumínio e uma caixa de
fósforos faz uma caixa inteira e comece
uma estrutura social exclusivo de
fósforo é isso mesmo avião expulso e
isto sim não faço em casa por pode ser
perigoso é um exclusivo então o que eu
preciso fazer é retirar todas as camisas
vermelhas postos e é preciso respeitar
isso tudo e juntar o pó ea cabeça dos
postos depois disso é só mudar tudo com
alumínio e matricular meu e vai dar uma
exclusão muito grande eu espero que dê
certo ok agora é para o santa que
encurtar este esforço no youtube
o pessoal tá tudo aqui pronto agora é só
entregar tudo e ir lá para fora
comentário eu vou tentar empurrar isso
com cuidado pois não explodir na minha
mão eu acho que não só de cinema que
suas fotos com impacto então é acho que
não é boa bola pessoal relatou que fora
só tem aqui também um exclusivo e vamos
lá estar então eu estou muito ansioso
por cento com poder e nada é preciso
ligar a câmera mas com a globo para lá
32 o vai não não funcionou por isso vou
tentar atravessar
o que aconteceu no distrito de uma
ouvido as cruz não muito bem por lá
então pessoal para o quinto e trocou
vejam só já tenho que nossa bola e é
muito fácil que sérgio tenha que cerca
de 200 fotos qualquer coisa correr mal é
só fazer isto agora lá sozinha em uma
série que vamos acender a bola em 321
vai nó já está sem medo já está sendo
tudo olhei ficou muito bonito o uol por
favor só como é que a nossa bola de fogo
eu vou pagar advogado
mas ainda faltam estado ainda faltam
tarde o que vou pagar eu vou ficar eu
vou pagar fósforo 321 paga tudo tudo
para ser um animal muito tempo por isso
o o tabu e quentinho e então aquilo roxo
e paris capital do congo detentora lei
é nova postura e só espero que vocês
tenham gostado deixei muito máquinas
trio isso não foi inscrito no canal
inscriã ã 16 pessoal fica em 6 até a
próxima atração